CONSTRUCTION OF THE WALL.
THEY ALREADY HAVE THE PRESIDENT
CONCEDE ON DACA BUT THEY PREFER
TO DEMAGOGUE RATHER THAN FIX THE
ISSUE.
SAD REALITY.
JOINING US NOW FOR MORE ON OUR
TOP STORY, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
SARA CARTER, INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER, AUTHOR, IT'S OUT SOON.
JULY IS COMING.
THE RUSSIA HOAX.
GREGG JARRETT, FOX NEWS LEGAL
ANALYST.
LET'S START WITH THE HEARINGS
TODAY.
AS YOU DIG DEEPER INTO THE IG
REPORT, ALL YOU SEE ARE ALL
THESE TRUMP-HATING LEAD
INVESTIGATORS.
THEN THE VERY SAME PEOPLE, THEY
PUT THE FIX IN AND RIGGED WHAT
WOULD'VE PUT ANY OTHER AMERICAN
IN JAIL WITH HILLARY, AND THEY
IMMEDIATELY GO START THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION ON TRUMP.
DOES THAT THEN DISQUALIFY AND
PUT INTO DOUBT FROM THE GET-GO
THE MUELLER WITCH HUNT?
>> IT ABSOLUTELY DOES.
AS JONATHAN TURLEY POINTED OUT,
THERE IS NO POSSIBLE WAY THAT
MUELLER CAN PURSUE OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP BECAUSE BOTH THE
IG AND THE ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS SAID COMEY
RICHLY DESERVED TO BE FIRED.
TODAY'S BEST MOMENT REALLY
HAPPENED ON THE CROSS
EXAMINATION BY SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
HE SAID I AM NOT BUYING THIS.
INSPECTOR GENERAL, THE BIAS AT
THE FBI WAS SO SEVERE, SO
PERVASIVE, IT HAD TO INFLUENCE T
PERVASIVE, IT HAD TO INFLUENCE E
PERVASIVE, IT HAD TO INFLUENCE D
PERVASIVE, IT HAD TO INFLUENCE C
PERVASIVE, IT HAD TO INFLUENCE S
PERVASIVE, IT HAD TO INFLUENCE O
PERVASIVE, IT HAD TO INFLUENCE N
PERVASIVE, IT HAD TO INFLUENCE T
PERVASIVE, IT HAD TO INFLUENCE O
CLEAR HILLARY CLINTON.
HE POINTED TO THE EXONERATION
STATEMENT THAT COMEY INITIALLY
FOUND CLINTON GUILTY UNDER THE
ESPIONAGE ACT BUT SOMEBODY
CHANGED THE LANGUAGE EVER SO
SLIGHTLY AND THAT IN ADDITION
ALLOWED COMEY TO EXONERATE
CLINTON WHEN IN FACT SHE HAD
COMMITTED A CRIME.
>> Sean: THE SWAMP ANSWER,
SARA, AS IT RELATES TO WE ARE
NOT GOING TO SECOND-GUESS
PROSECUTORIAL DISCRETION, AS
THEY CALL IT HERE.
TELL THAT TO KRISTIAN SAUCIER.
HE SPENT A YEAR IN JAIL AND
THERE WERE MANY OTHER EXAMPLES,
AS WE POINTED OUT IN OUR PROGRAM
AS WE POINTED OUT IN OUR PROGRA
PROGRAM.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THAT HE
WON'T MAKE THAT DETERMINATION
BUT THEN THE ENTIRE REPORT JUST
EXAMPLE AFTER EXAMPLE OF
BLATANT CORRUPTION AND BIAS BY
THE TOP PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THIS
AND HOW MUCH THEY LOVE HILLARY,
PROTECT HER.
THEN THE SAME PEOPLE TAKE A
SLEDGEHAMMER AND LITERALLY TRY
AND DESTROY TRUMP FROM THE
GET-GO.
>> SEAN, I THINK THIS WAS SUCH
AN IMPORTANT HEARING TODAY.
GREGG IS RIGHT ON THE MONEY.
I THINK SENATOR GRAHAM GAVE THE
BEST CROSS-EXAMINATION EVER.
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT CAME OUT OF THAT.
THAT EXONERATION, THAT CHANGE IN
LANGUAGE, ACTUALLY APPEARS TO BE
THE INSURANCE POLICY THAT PETER
STRZOK WAS TALKING ABOUT WITH
LISA PAGE, HIS PARAMOUR.
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR AN
INSURANCE POLICY.
IN ANOTHER TEXT MESSAGE AND IN
THAT SAME TEXT MESSAGE, LET ME
GO BACK TO THAT.
THEY TALK ABOUT ANDY'S OFFICE.
ANDY McCABE.
IT WOULD BE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
ANDREW MCCABE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT QUESTION WAS
THE ONE THAT SENATOR GRAHAM
ASKED.
IT WAS ANDREW MCCABE IN THAT
MEETING WITH PETER STRZOK AND
LISA PAGE?
AND WE NEED TO KNOW THAT FROM
STRZOK AND PAGE.
THOSE TWO NEED TO BE
INTERVIEWED.
AND THEN ANDREW MCCABE NEEDS TO
BE INTERVIEWED AGAIN.
THESE ARE THAT'S THE CASE, IF HE
WAS IN THAT MEETING, THIS IS THE
MOST FRIGHTENING, FRIGHTENING
EXAMPLE OF FBI POWER SINCE
J. EDGAR HOOVER.
AMERICANS SHOULD BE TERRIFIED OF
IT.
THEY WERE RIGGING AN ELECTION.
>> Sean: AND THAT'S THE WHOLE
POINT HERE.
THAT'S WHY IT'S THE BIGGEST
ABUSE OF POWER, OPTION SCANDAL
EVER.
THE SIMILARITIES IN TERMS OF THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION AND THE
HILLARY RIGGED INVESTIGATION ARE
EERIE IN THIS WAY,
GREGG JARRETT.
IN AS MUCH AS YOU HAVE ALL OF
THESE SAME PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED HERE, AND THEN YOU LOOK
AT JEANNIE RAY AND ANDREW
WEISSMANN AND ALL THE DEMOCRATIC
DONORS.
IT IS THE SAME CORRUPTION THAT
WILL ONLY BE EXPOSED DOWN THE
LINE, ALTHOUGH WE'VE KNOWN FOR A
LONG TIME, IN ROBERT MILLER'S
WITCH HUNT.
IT'S NO DIFFERENT.
>> IT SORT OF MAKES YOU WONDER
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
WORK AT THE FBI, PETER STRZOK,
LISA PAGE, ANDY McCABE AND
JAMES COMEY HIM AND AFTER ALL,
THEY COMMANDEERED THIS CASE AWAY
FROM THAT FIELD OFFICE.
WHY DID THEY DO THAT?
THEY WANTED TO CONTROL IT.
IT WAS ALSO BEING CONTROLLED BY
THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE.
THAT'S ABUNDANTLY CLEAR.
AND YES, MUELLER EXAMPLED A TEAM
OF PARTISANS, SOME OF WHOM WERE
ALSO IN ON THE HILLARY CLINTON